carottes choux navets pommes de terre
franck echard produit une quarantaine de
variétés sur ces trois hectares il est
très intéressé par les projets du
département qui lui permettrait de
garder ses salariés et peut-être même
d'engager d'autres nous intéresse c'est
que ça serait des quantités assez
précises au début de saison comme ça
nous on pourrait prévoir mon planning
plus en amont pour pouvoir perd juste ce
qu'il faut qu'on aurait moins de pertes
et surtout pour fournir tout ce qui est
école qui nous intéresse pas ce sont les
salades que ce maraîcher souhaiterait
vendre au collège en priorité salades
cultivées sous bâche jusqu'à décembre
sans aucun traitement
ces légumes ne sont pas labellisés bio
mais ils répondent aux critères du
département une production raisonnée à
haute valeur environnementale
aujourd'hui bras vont faire du bio c'est
pas évident que ça c'est pas aussi
évident que ça parce qu'il ya tout un
environnement qui fait qu' il n'est pas
bio des molécules de glyphosate ces
volatiles donc ça même si on est en bio
ça peut venir se coller sur nos légumes
à nous alors je préfère être honnête
avec toute notre clientèle dire voilà on
n'emploie pas de d'herbicides et après
tout ce qu'à l'intérieur des serres on
achète des insectes auxiliaires c'est à
dire que c'est des insectes qui mange
tout les pucerons
on investit tous les ans pour être de
plus en plus proche du bio mais on sera
jamais au tip-top byblos et malgré nous
c'est pas possible
le maraîcher est prêt pour se lancer
dans l'aventuré des cantines des
collèges
mais voilà il n'a pas encore eu de
commandes fermes de la part du
département
direction la ferme de la motte attal si
une autre échelle de production
cinquante cinq mille tonnes d'oignons
échalotes et pommes de terre bio sorte
de ses chaînes chaque année une grande
partie vient de la région centre la
ferme de la motte peut fournir au
collège des produits de même qualité
toute l'année donc en oignon en fournir
à ce type de conditionnement en plus
tandis kg des oignons assez gros qui
vont plus vite à éplucher
pour la restauration et qui prennent pas
trop de place mais pour s'engager avec
le département l'entreprise familiale a
besoin de l'assurance de commandes
régulières de gros volumes sachant que
le on est sur des produits qui sont à
des pépins ne s'est pas des prix s'est
pas vendu cher quand reviennent mais
quoi ce qui fait qu'il faudrait pas que
ça coûte plus cher de transport par
rapport au produit donc aujourd'hui
livré 20 ou 30 kg d'oignons par semaine
on pourra pas passer gens comme nous ça
ça passera pas économiquement
il faudrait qu'on puisse livrer sur une
palette de 5 600 kg pouvoir regrouper
plusieurs produits sur une palette et
avec régulièrement une dizaine de
producteurs du loir et cher sont
volontaires et en capacité de produire
pour les cantines des collèges
ils attendent des réponses sur
l'organisation pour pouvoir adhérer au
projet du conseil départemental
[Musique]